[MUSIC PLAYING]
MISHA BRUKMAN: Hello, everyone,
and welcome to the session.
Today we're going
to talk about how
to visualize Cloud
Bigtable access
patterns with Visual Analytics.
And with us today we have
Steve Niemitz from Twitter,
and we have Wim de
Pauw, an engineering
manager of Google Cloud.
My name is Misha Brukman,
and I'm a Product Manager
on Big table on Google Cloud.
With that, Steve, take it away.
STEVE NIEMITZ: Thank you.
All right.
So hey, everybody.
I'm Steve Nemitz.
I'm a software
engineer at Twitter.
I'm the team lead for our
revenue data analytics product.
We basically focus on serving
analytic queries specifically
for our advertiser analytics.
So let's talk about
Twitter a little bit,
just a little background for
people unfamiliar with it.
So we have around 300 plus
million monthly active users.
Of those users,
they're generally
generating around 100
million tweets per day.
That turns into something
like 300 petabytes of data
that we have stored on HDFS.
And we're a global company.
We have pops in over
five continents.
So specifically, now, let's
talk about advertiser analytics.
So we have all those users
interacting on the platform.
Our advertiser
analytics product is
what we use to provide
to our advertisers
in order to get information on
how their ads and campaigns are
performing.
So they can see things like
spend breakdown, impressions,
clicks, all these
metrics in real time
through UIs that
we provide to them,
and also APIs for our
more advanced advertisers.
So the skill that we operate
on here is pretty large.
We have over
hundreds of thousands
of active advertisers
at any given times.
Those advertisers are
running lots of campaigns.
And all those campaigns
are generating
hundreds of thousands
of events per second.
Those could be coming
from client events,
from the web browsers,
mobile apps, all of stuff.
But even internal applications
that we have like our ad
serving infrastructure,
those are all
generating events that
go through our pipeline.
So all in all, it's
around 20 terabytes
a day of raw log data.
And our pipelines will take
that and compress it down
and aggregate it to about
eight terabytes a year of data.
So in all, our analytic
data set size is somewhere
on the order of 50
terabytes, but growing
as we speak right now.
So let's talk about what
are the requirements
that we need to
provide in the SLOs we
try to achieve for
this analytics service
that we provide.
The queries need to be fast.
So these things are
powering interactive UIs.
They're powering APIs that
our advertisers are using.
So we try to shoot
for pretty tight SLAs.
Our SLA is 4.5 seconds on many
of these queries, pretty much
all of the queries, which can
be for things like give me
three years of data hourly, or
give me the last week of data
just aggregated together.
We generally have
around 5,000 QPS,
which turns into around a
gigabyte a second of data
that we're processing
at any given time
just for query execution.
And we obviously have a pretty
high SLO on uptime, 9997.
So let's talk more about the
queries we're serving here.
So things like give me
all of the impressions
that my promoted tweets have
generated for the last seven
days.
Show me the spend
that my campaigns have
had over the last month
totaled up in sum together.
Let's say give me the
impressions by day for only app
installs by iOS users.
So we get really granular
with some of these queries
and can break them down
and segment them many ways.
And then other things
like hourly spend
broken down by geography.
So like how much do people
in Japan spend on tweets?
All of these things can
turn into some problems
that we'll run into when we
try to scale off the shelf
systems up.
The dimensionality of
this data is very high.
We have at least 20 high
cardinality dimensions,
things like geography,
interests, things like that.
And additionally, we
also have another 20
or so lower
cardinality dimensions
that we need to query over.
So a lot of the
systems we've looked at
weren't really designed for
this level of QPS and latency.
They were more for ad hoc
internal analytics of,
like, maybe there's a BA that's
trying to do some investigation
and is just running a couple
of queries per minute.
So that brings us to why
we used Cloud Bigtable.
We decided to use this
as our analytic database
and basically build analytic
product on top of it.
So reasons we chose
it, it's fully managed,
which is awesome.
We don't have to
run any hardware.
run any software.
We don't have to worry
about upgrading it ever.
All of that's handled for us.
It's very scalable, and
it's very easy to scale.
I can just go into the UI
or use the API or whatever,
and add another 20 nodes and
scale up my cluster by 20%,
and it just happens instantly.
I don't have to worry about
requisitioning hardware
and getting that kind of stuff.
It's very high performance.
It's basically linearly
scalable to any size,
assuming you have
good key design, which
we'll talk about later in this.
And the actual schema and
the design of the system
makes it really well sorted
for the high performance time
series analytics
that we want to do.
So with that, I'm going
to hand it over to Misha
to talk more about Bigtable.
MISHA BRUKMAN: Thank you, Steve.
So let's talk about Google
Cloud Bigtable and the feature
set that it provides to
enable Steve and his team
to do the analytics at scale.
So what is Bigtable?
Bigtable is a
sparse, distributed,
persistent,
multidimensional sorted map.
That's the description that you
can see in the paper from 2006.
So let's dive into details
for a bunch of these different
attributes and see how
they work in practice.
Bigtable is a distributed
key multivalue store.
It is sparse in the sense that
unwritten cells don't take up
any space, so you
don't have to fill out
every single cell
in every single row
for every single column family.
It supports atomic
single row transactions
so you can modify any values
across any of the column
families.
And it has a single index,
which is the row keys,
so there are no secondary
indices for any of the columns
that you see except
for the row key.
And in this table,
you can see how
you would access the
different cells in the table
by using the row key, column
family, and column qualifier
to uniquely identify them.
Cloud Bigtable supports the
multi-dimensional map model
as follows.
For a tuple of
values, the row, which
is a string, a column, which
is a combination of column
family and an optional
column qualifier,
together with an N64 timestamp,
given all of those values,
you can retrieve the value.
And the value is an
uninterpreted array of bytes.
And so here you can see that
you have a built-in time
dimension that you can
use to store time series.
In fact, while most databases
are two-dimensional,
Bigtable is actually
three-dimensional.
So the third dimension
in Bigtable is time.
Every cell has an arbitrary
number of versions,
and there is an N64 attached
to each one of those cell
versions.
You can treat them as time.
You can also treat them as
an arbitrary version ID,
so you could just give them
numeric incrementing numbers.
You can store an
arbitrary number of them,
but you can also enable
automatic garbage collection,
either based on time
or based on count.
So you don't have to manually
go in and clean up and delete
the unnecessary values.
You can keep just writing
into Bigtable setup policy,
and Bigtable will asynchronously
remove data after some time
or after you've reached
a limit such as you
say keep the last five values,
and Bigtable will automatically
garbage collect them
asynchronously over time.
Let's talk about the Request
Routing mechanism in Bigtable.
Bigtable clients connect
to a single endpoint, which
is the load balancing
proxy layer,
and it then forwards the
request to the Bigtable
nodes that serve the data.
In the following
set of slides I'm
going to remove
the load balancing
proxy layer for clarity.
But keep in mind that clients
don't necessarily connect
directly to the Bigtable nodes.
The requests are routed
through this API layer.
So here you can see the clients
are connecting to Bigtable.
Bigtable doesn't
actually store any data,
which is kind of
interesting for a database.
Bigtable itself is
stateless because it
stores all the data in Colossus,
our distributed file system.
Here you can see that a
Bigtable node manages data
without holding onto
the data in Colossus.
So Bigtable nodes have
exclusive read write access
to sections of the
data in a table
to provide the atomicity
of updates to a single row.
So every row in
Bigtable is exclusively
managed by at most one node.
Nodes don't talk to
each other, so there
are no cross-row
transactions in this case.
But this allows for
variable scalability.
Here the A, B, C, D, and
E are sorted key ranges
within a single table.
So as we mentioned
earlier, the storage model
sorts the keys in the
table to allow you
for fast linear scans.
Now let's say we have
a single node that
is getting a lot of
activity because there
is a lot of popular
data that is being
accessed by a bunch of clients.
What Bigtable table
can do is simply
reassign the ownership of
that data to a different node,
and that is an online operation
without any data motion.
So regardless of the
gigabytes or terabytes of data
that you've just reassigned,
this is an online operation,
and without any data
copying, the data
stays exactly where
it was in Colossus,
and this is just
a metadata update
to show that there's
new owner of this data,
and the requests
flow automatically.
The client is completely
unaware of this
because their requests
are automatically
forwarded by the load balancing
proxy layer that I mentioned
earlier.
So clients don't need to do
any discovery or any updates
or management of who do
they need to connect to.
They have a single endpoint,
they connect to that,
and the requests are
routed automatically,
even when the data is rebalanced
and reassigned at scale.
This ability to easily
reassign the data
and the strong separation
between the processing storage
enables the simple scalability
that Steve mentioned earlier.
What this means is that
if we add another node
to the cluster, as
you can see here,
we can easily shard and reassign
the data to other nodes.
And so the cluster will scale
in performance in linear order
compared with the number
of nodes in the cluster.
You don't have to do
anything to enable this.
You just add more
nodes to the cluster
and you get the additional
throughput in the cluster
given the size of nodes.
Similarly, of course, you
can shrink down the cluster,
and we will again resize and
we balance the assignments
to fit that smaller cluster.
What this means is that you
can get seamless scalability
in scaling for Cloud Bigtable
without any downtime.
And as Steve alluded, you get
the linear scalability ability
if you have good schema design.
Now what does that mean to
have a good schema design?
We'll talk about
this in a bit as
to how you can get
good schema design
and what it actually
means for Bigtable,
and what performs well.
But before we get to that, let's
talk about some of the recent
features that we've
announced for Cloud Bigtable.
Yesterday we announced
that Cloud Bigtable now
supports replication, and it
is now generally available.
There are no manual steps
to enable replication
of synchronization, or
any steps to repair data,
or anything to synchronize
on your writes or deletes.
This is automatically
handled for you
as soon as you add another
cluster to an instance.
And some of the use cases that
you might consider for this
are either high availability
for serving or workflow
separation for batch
and serving use cases.
As I mentioned, as
of yesterday, it
increases the SLA
from 95 to 9995
and a zero touch
failover for HA.
So with that, let's return
to the row schema design
and how that
impacts performance.
As Steve mentioned, good
row key schema design
is crucial for performance
to get the linear scalability
because the row
key schema design
will guide the access
patterns, and you
want to make sure that your
access patterns scale linearly
to enable linear scaling for
the performance in your Bigtable
cluster.
If you have uneven
access patterns,
you'll end up with hotspots.
If you're storing too much
data due to the row key schema
design in a single row, you
will also you have trouble doing
that because since we cannot
split a single row across
multiple nodes in Bigtable, you
will have single servers that
are really trying to serve
a single role that maybe
gigabytes in size.
So in the end, you really
want balanced access banners,
you want reasonably
sized rows, and that
will provide the
linear scalability
that you have with Bigtable.
Traditional monitoring
involves line charts,
such as this one, where you
can look at CPU utilization,
you can see latency, you can
see data stored and such.
So this will show you,
for example, this graph,
CPU utilization on
average in a cluster.
We also have CPU utilization
for the hottest node
in the cluster, which might hint
at the possibility of hotspots.
But what if you
wanted to know more?
What if you wanted to see
what is actually happening
under the covers, and how is it
that you can improve your row
key schema design to
improve performance?
How would you know if
you had large rows?
How would you know that
there's a map produced
that may be affecting
your serving latency?
How would you debug if
you really have high CPU
and find what the cause
of that high CPU might be?
With that, I want
to hand it over
to Wim, who will talk about
a new feature for Cloud
Bigtable, Key Visualizer.
Wim?
WIM DE PAUW: Thank you, Misha.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Wim de Pauw.
I'm the Engineering Manager
of the Visual Analytics
team in New York and very proud
to announce Key Visualizer
for Cloud Bigtable.
This is a novel
approach to analyze
the behavior of your table.
You saw the line chart before.
Well, typical line charts,
they only show one dimension.
We show read and write access
patterns, both over time
and the keyspace.
This will help you find
and prevent hotspots.
You can find rows
with too much data,
and you can see if your
key schema is balanced.
This is the heat map
if Key Visualizer.
It will show time horizontally.
It proceeds from left to right.
This example shows one week
of behavior of your Bigtable.
The keyspace is shown
vertically with the lowest
keys at the bottom and the
highest keys at the top.
Then there's the heat scale.
You can see it has colors
from cold, in black, for zero,
and then it goes to
dark blue, red, yellow,
to glowing white hot for
extremely high values.
In this example here, you
can see a diurnal pattern.
You see this lowest
key range over here?
Well, there's about
seven hotspots here.
So someone must have hammered
that key range very heavily
every night.
Over there you see a cold
area because it's practically
completely dark.
And this horizontal line in the
middle that is glowing white
must be a key that has been
used very, very heavily.
In this example here,
you see a diagonal line,
which is probably a sequential
scan from a MapReduce job.
And then, if in Key
Visualizer, if you
hover with the mouse
over the screen,
you'll see in the tool tip more
details like the actual value,
the precise time,
and then the start
and the end key of the region
that you're hovering over.
Around the heat map, you'll
see at the bottom end
on the right aggregate
values in bar charts.
So here at the bottom
you see averages
over divisible keyspace
in 15-minute intervals.
This is pretty much
what you would see
in your traditional line chart.
On the right side here,
there's another bar chart
that shows you averages
over visible time
range per key range.
You see that spike over here?
Remember, that was that bright
white line of that hot key
that we had in the middle.
Now when we were observing
Bigtable application developers
at Google, we observed that
very often, although not always,
they were creating their
keys in a hierarchical value,
in a hierarchical way.
So they were using prefixes and
concatenating these prefixes
a little bit like this example.
This example here uses
slashes and dashes.
It could be other symbols, too.
And so we thought, we're
going to, in Key Visualizer,
extract the prefix tree so that
you can see your key schema
in the heat map.
So the result of that will
look something like that.
So here you see an icicle chart.
And the leftmost
tall, thin rectangle
here shows you the top prefix.
And then as you go right,
you see prefixes going down
the hierarchy.
Why is this useful?
Well, first of all, you can now
see your key schema of the data
that you designed.
And hopefully you can
recognize the data
that you stored that way.
The other thing is that we
often observed that behavior is
correlated with the key layout.
So in this example here, this
is a very small key range,
and you see that corresponds to
a series of key prefixes here.
And it's a very
distinct pattern.
You see this on and off pattern
over four days over here,
all correlated with
the key prefix.
Key Visualizer gives
you 11 metrics.
First of all, we give you
ops, which is the sum of reads
and writes.
Then we give you
three warning metrics
that can point you to
possibly bad performance.
I'll talk about that later on.
Then we have reads, writes.
We have performance
metrics like latency.
And finally, we have the amount
of data that is stored per row.
Let me show you now some
common key access patterns.
So over here you see
an imbalanced keyspace.
Again, remember, time
goes horizontally
from left to right.
And you see that about
20% of the top keys
here were very heavily used.
They're glowing yellow and red,
whereas the 80% at the bottom,
they're barely used because you
can see that it's very cold.
In this example, you see that
your database was pretty much
cold over the
whole key spectrum.
But then all of a
sudden, at this time,
you see a very sudden increase
for a key range from here
to here.
When we look at
that example here,
you see that everything
is pretty much
cold except for a few
glowing white keys.
So that's an example of a couple
of hotspots that we see here.
And then finally
in this example,
this is the same example
that I pointed you out
in the previous slides here.
You see this
diagonal line, which
is probably a sequential read
caused by a MapReduce job.
Now Key Visualizer is not
just about visualization.
It's also about analysis,
analysis on possibly trillions
of metric values.
So imagine if you have a
database with a trillion rows.
If we want to show that
behavior on your laptop,
we have to downsample
and aggregate it
in one way or another
to get it to your laptop
in less than a minute.
So we have to aggregate
and downsample
all these performance metrics.
Then, on the other
hand, we also analyze
every single performance value
that we collect in the system,
and they're very detailed.
The result of that
is three metrics.
The first one is the
read pressure index.
And that is a function, an
opaque function of read CPU,
read queue length,
which is the number
of read operations waiting
to be executed, and latency.
And that function can point
you to possibly bad read
performance.
We have something similar
for write behavior.
And then finally,
we have large rows
which will point you to
any rows that contain
more than one gigabyte of data.
Now, this is a massive amount
of calculations and data
that we analyze.
But the good news
is that this has
absolutely no performance
impact on your cluster,
absolutely not.
And it's all for free.
This is an example here
of a high read pressure.
You see this glowing spot.
Now some of you may
think, well, this
may be a little bit overwhelming
because I have 11 metrics.
I have all that data.
Where do I start?
We made it easy for you.
So when you open Key
Visualizer, it opens with ops.
That's the default metric.
And what it shows you is just
an overview of your activity.
You see if there's any hot
regions, any cold regions,
if you have any diurnal
patterns, any linear scans.
And then you'll see if there's
any warnings at the top bar.
If there aren't any
warnings, that's good news.
Then there's nothing to do.
You can just relax.
If there are warnings,
and they will show up
like this example
over here, then you
click on the button
to see which keys
and when they were
causing problems.
I'm going to show
you an example now.
So imagine you open Key
Visualizer in the ops view.
You see an overview
of your behavior.
This is one week.
And you see what's
hot and what is cold,
and the diurnal patterns.
And over there, which I've
annotated in the red rectangle,
you see this read
pressure warning.
It has three exclamation marks,
so that means it's severe.
I click on that button, and
it brings me immediately
to the read pressure
index metric.
You see this glowing
white stripe over here?
So when I hover over
it with the tool tip,
I see immediately the
details of the problems.
So I've got a list
of problems here.
But the most severe one
is the one at the top
here, which I've annotated
with the red rectangle.
And I'm going to
zoom into that now.
So what is this?
Well, you see it's
glowing, so it's bad.
So first of all,
this is a single key.
And it's been stressed
for two hours and a half.
So that's pretty long.
The other thing
which you can see
is the exact name of the
offending key, shown over here
in the second line.
And why do we think
that it's bad?
Well, look at the
total read CPU.
It's using 446 millinodes,
which is roughly half a server
worth of CPU.
Remember, this is
just for one key.
And then we also give
the potential culprit,
the suggestion of what
probably was causing this.
Well, we're dealing
with a large row here.
So look at this.
This is 10.38 gigabyte.
And you know that
the recommended row
size, the maximum row size in
Bigtable, is 256 megabytes.
So this is way too
much, of course.
But you imagine someone is
hammering that key very hard,
pulling out all that data,
and each time they're
pulling out 10 gigabytes.
No wonder that this is
going to use a lot of CPU.
See, this is how easy it
was, I open Key Visualizer.
I look at the overview,
click on the alert buttons,
and it shows me the problem.
What we've shown you
so far are metrics
that are views that are showing
one metric, for example, ops.
And you can imagine
that you're looking
at, say, a read hot spot.
And you may want
to know, well, am I
also writing at this
time and space and place?
And you switch to writing.
And then you want to see
is there any latency,
and you switch to latency.
And so this was a
little bit cumbersome.
We thought to make this
a little bit easier.
So this new feature,
which we probably
will launch in a couple
of weeks from now,
is the Multiple Metrics View.
So here in the middle, you
see what we had before.
When I hover with my
cursor over an area,
I see in the tool
tip the values.
But now, at the same time,
I see all the metric values
for each metric over
there on the right side.
So this lets you compare
and correlate metrics
simultaneously just in one view.
In this example here,
you see that the
reads that are in purple,
they're somewhat lukewarm,
whereas the writes,
they're bright yellow.
So we're doing not so
much reading, but a lot
of writing in this example.
And then there's the Expand
All button over there.
So if I click on that
one, this will bring up
miniature views for
each metric that
are showing the same
window as the main view.
So here I had ops.
Over there I had the
number of bytes written.
Over here I have the
number of data stored,
and here the number of rows.
And if I hover with the
cursor over the main view,
the cursor will simultaneously
change over here,
and you see the
corresponding metrics also.
If I zoom in and out, and
if I pan in the main view,
all of these view will
just move and will
be zooming in synchronized.
So that will be coming
in a couple of weeks.
Let me summarize to give you,
again, a couple of the benefits
that I've demonstrated so far.
So it helps you detect and
prevent key access hotspots.
It helps you find large
rows more than one gigabyte.
And there's no performance
impact for you at all.
And it's free.
One use case that I did
not illustrate over here
is how to optimize
your key schema.
And that's what
Steve is now going
to talk about
because he used Key
Visualizer for that purpose.
STEVE NIEMITZ: Thank you.
So as Wim introduced,
now we're going
to talk about how we used
this feature while we were
developing our analytics
product in order to tune
and really optimize the data.
So one of the things we realized
while we were building this
is that the key schema
and the row key schema
really matters a lot for
how well the performance
of your Bigtable will be.
Again, poor key schema
design will end up
with a very nonscalable
Bigtable design.
So a few common things that
we realized we needed to do
is that we should tune our
data to the query patterns
that we were expecting,
which kind of makes sense.
So in building our
row keys, we basically
want the queries, the
dimensions in those queries,
to match the row key
from left to right.
So you add some dimensions,
you put them in your row key
in a serialized form.
You want to be
able to match them
left to right to get optimum
data querying in your queries.
Also, you want your row
keys to be well distributed
across the whole keyspace.
Otherwise you're not going to
have a very linearly scalable
system because only
certain nodes will be
serving a majority of the data.
And also, you want your queries
to have the minimum number
of scans required in order
to keep your commonly
accessed data together.
So what we're going
to do now is I'm
going to introduce just
an example, a kind of toy
key schema that's a
simplified version of what
we use for our actual
advertiser analytics.
And we'll walk through some
simulated traffic on it
and see what they looked
like in Key Visualizer,
and how we improved the design.
So here are some
simple dimensions.
You can imagine
advertiser ID is just
the ID we give any advertiser
that signs up with us.
A campaign ID is a
campaign they're running.
So maybe it's an ad they're
showing, something like that.
Timestamp is the time the data
that we're querying corresponds
to.
Generally we group things
into an hour granularity.
So the timestamp will
be at the hour level.
Engagement type is just kind
of like what the user did
to engage with the ad.
Did they view it,
did they click on it,
did they install an application,
something like that.
And then display location
is where it was on the page.
Was it in their timeline,
was it a search result,
things like that.
So basically our first
iteration was really simple.
So let's take all of these
dimensions concatenated
together from left to right,
and that becomes our row key.
So timestamp, advertiser
ID, campaign ID, et cetera,
et cetera.
There are some pros here.
It's really easy to scan
across all advertisers
if you have a time range, and
generally all of our queries
will have a time range in them.
You have good data locality
because all the data
for an advertiser
is grouped together.
But now let's
check out the cons.
So this is a view of
what our Key Visualizer
looks like with this schema.
This isn't great.
So we have here, there's a big
spot of basically no traffic.
Up here you can see there's
a very pronounced line
of hot keys, which
generally will
correspond to the current week
of data we're looking at here.
Most of the queries for
our data that we have
are querying for the
most recent data.
That makes sense.
People care more about
what's happening now
than what happened in the past.
So this isn't great.
This is not a
really good design.
If we had run this
in production,
we'd probably have
very hot nodes
all the time because
whatever node
was hosting this small
key range in the middle
here would be
overloaded all the time.
So let's iterate.
Let's take what we learned
here and see what we can do.
So we learned timestamp was
not great to put in the front.
So let's swap timestamp
and advertiser ID.
What this is going to
do now is the advertiser
ID is at the
beginning of my key.
And the timestamp
is within there.
So it's still easy to
scan for a time range
within an advertiser.
It's harder to query
for all advertisers.
However, in our use cases,
that's not really something
we care about.
Advertisers coming in are
only looking at their data.
Obviously we're not going to
let them query for anything.
So although we have a
con here, it's not really
the end of the world.
It doesn't really fit
our use case anyways.
So let's look at
what happened here.
We got a little better.
So there's more distribution.
However, we still have some
hot keys, some hot ranges here.
These most likely
will correspond
to advertisers that are
more frequently querying
for their data.
Additionally, our
advertiser ID keys might not
be very well distributed
across the entire keyspace.
They're probably
sequentially generated
integers or something.
So in that case, we'll end
up with groupings of like,
we probably generated a bunch
of IDs here and then here.
And those are all
groups that add factors.
So let's iterate again.
We've learned that we put
advertiser ID in front,
things worked out
a little better.
However, we didn't get
a good distribution
on that advertiser ID keyspace.
So instead, let's reverse
the advertiser ID.
Basically the first digit
is now the last digit, which
will basically
synthetically distribute
the keys a lot
better because now,
instead of the most significant
bit that's generally not
changing much, you have
the least significant bit,
which is always
cycling all the time
if they're sequentially
generated IDs.
So pros and cons are
basically the same now.
There's not a big
difference other
than you couldn't scan
advertiser IDs sequentially.
But we don't care.
That's not a use case anyways.
So this is what we end up with.
Everything looks pretty good.
We still have some rows here
which correspond, probably,
to more frequently
accessed advertisers that
are pulling their data more.
But in general, the
keyspace is really
well distributed across
basically the entire range.
This is what we want
it to look like.
And this will lead to a
really well-performing design.
So the really
important thing here
is because we were
able to do this,
it really gave us confidence
that when we took this product
and went live with it,
that we wouldn't end up
with horrible
performance issues,
and we wouldn't have to
redesign it in a year
because it wouldn't scale.
It's also been
really helpful for us
if we have a production
issue come up,
like why is our latency going
up for certain advertisers,
or things like that.
We can go right
into Key Visualizer
and see what's
happening at the time.
And now I'm going to
hand it over to Misha.
MISHA BRUKMAN: So as you've
seen, Steve at Twitter
was able to use
Bigtable at the scale
that Twitter needs to
do visual analytics
and serve their ads analytics.
Bigtable provides the fully
managed, NoSQL database
to serve these
types of use cases
for time series user
analytics as well as others.
It provides
petabyte-scale scalability
for storage, high throughput and
low latency for random access.
And it provides the ability
to seamlessly redistribute
the data to handle
increases in load,
and seamless scalability
while adjusting
to the access patterns
that you can put on it.
And you can learn more
about it at the URL.
WIM DE PAUW: So Key
Visualizer, which
is in beta now for
Cloud Bigtable,
visualizes your key
access patterns.
It will help you find
hotspots and large rows.
And it's not just visualization.
We also analyze trillions
of metric values.
It extracts the key prefix
hierarchy if it's available.
And it doesn't have any
impact on the performance
of your cluster.
There's a URL here that you
can go to for more information.
STEVE NIEMITZ: And then
finally, some of the really key
features that Bigtable
and Key Visualizer
enabled for us at Twitter.
It really gave us
a very fast time
to market on bringing in
this new improved advertiser
analytics product up to scale.
Additionally, using
Key Visualizer
gave us really good
confidence that we
would be able to scale up
and end up with a scalably
designed system.
We were able to iterate
on the row key design way
faster than we would
have been if we
had to infer it through other
metrics like P99 latency,
things like that.
And then finally, it
made it really easy
to change the row key
schema during development
and just see what happened.
It let us iterate
really quickly,
but without going
live in production
and actually having to
worry about impacting that.
So that's all we have.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]